contrasts themselves are the very basis
of architectural experience the
experience of a quality is sharpened and
made tangible by connection with its
bipolar opposite
coolness is experienced in relation to a
sense of warmth and cozy containment is
experienced in reference to soaring
openness
and the awareness of light is anchored
by darkness
and when we carefully design a link
between these two opposing conditions
we're actually elevating and nurturing
some of these uh fundamental human needs
today i just want to talk about the
relationship and the contrast between
the inside and the outside
and i want to give you five strategies
on how you can create this inside and
outside condition
and
some of the different ways you can link
these two conditions
[Music]
hey guys my name is demi and i am a
licensed architect in a very wet rainy
vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture in the summer of
2013 my friend and i traveled across the
u.s with the goal of visiting every
single frank lloyd wright building
scattered across north america we ended
up visiting a grand total of 25 cities
and 111 frank lloyd wright buildings we
heard beautiful and sometimes tragic
stories from dozens of homeowners and
this experience has obviously
transformed the way that i see things
and the way that i design but
i have always kind of felt like these
design strategies came from
intuition rather than it being a learned
skill
and then recently i came across this
book called the good house
i'll leave the link below
and this book breaks down some of the
strategies that i saw in so many of the
frank lloyd wright's buildings so in
this video and in the next series of
videos i want to distill some of the
concepts and strategies and try to break
it down into a series of simple
straightforward design strategies that
you can use when designing small
buildings or houses
so inside and outside are
of course interlinked
you can't create an inside without
shaping the outside and the link
provides a transition between inside and
outside
concave spaces make it feel like you're
inside and convex spaces make it feel
like you're outside
straight corners are used to create a
more defined space and round corners
make the space feel more spacious
because the boundaries are harder to
perceive but of course round spaces come
with their own challenges because
it's pretty hard to place furniture in a
round living room
boundaries don't necessarily have to be
defined with walls you can define
boundaries with landscape elements like
bushes or benches or rocks
like in this instance we don't have any
walls but
you can still see that the boundaries
are pretty clearly defined and it really
feels like its own enclosed space
one simple way to create this inside
outside condition without moving around
a bunch of walls is just playing around
with the transparency of the wall the
more opaque surfaces it feels more like
you're inside and the more transparent
it is you feel more connected to the
outside
courier schemes are interesting because
you're creating kind of a totally new
condition
you're
capturing a piece of the outdoors but
you're in an enclosed space
because technically you're in an outside
space but you're enclosed with walls on
all sides
and it makes you feel like you're
somewhere between inside and outside
[Music]
if a building establishes geometric
order then that order is going to
radiate out into the landscape for
example when we're outside we can feel
the geometry of the inside and when
we're inside we can sense the building's
order radiating out into the landscape
if you hear an architect freaking out
about how the interior floor tiles don't
align with the tiles of the porch
they're not saying that just to be well
maybe they are but because it's a way we
create continuity between the inside and
outside if you have a really symmetrical
building you can continue that symmetry
onto the landscape and as soon as you
step off the axis that's when you truly
feel outside even though we don't have
any actual walls creating that boundary
the versailles a great example we were
actually just there two years ago and
it's incredible how the architecture
creates a grid and establishes authority
by radiating that grid out all the way
into the landscape
in between spaces are places like
porches patios and arcades
and at a smaller scale it can be a deep
doorway or a window ledge to convey that
sense of in-betweenness before we go
into our next strategy i want to share a
quick message from our sponsor one of
the problems i've always had is that
architecture products that i love are so
freaking expensive
and that's why i was so happy when i
discovered pacific arc
because they have high quality durable
products similar to rotaring but at a
fraction of a price
and so i don't feel so paranoid about
losing my pencil when i take it out for
sketching or take it out on a job site
i've been testing out their products for
the past couple of weeks and i'm really
surprised at the durability and quality
they're able to deliver at such a good
price i've been working with pacific arc
to curate a kit of product so there's
three kits one of them is for those of
you starting school so it includes all
the fundamental architectural supplies
that you're going to need to get through
school and there's another kit that
includes the tools that we keep around
our office and the third kit is a kit of
basic products that i use on a daily
basis
if you use my code in the description
they're going to be giving you a 30
discount for black friday and after that
it'll be a 15 discount
so take advantage of it while you can
okay back to the strategies in the house
that means van der rohe designed for the
1931 berlin exhibition
he blurs the inside and outside by
continuing the walls all the way from
the inside all the way to the outside
and creates a kind of interlocking
condition
you can also place kind of unexpected
interior elements outside like locating
a fireplace outside or locating a couch
outside
if this was interesting for you you
might also be interested in strategies
you can use to present your designs i
have a video on presentation tips right
here
also if you want to check out some of my
designs i have videos like the one on
how i turn my anxieties into an
architectural experience i'll leave it
right here
i'd love to know have you visited any
frank lloyd wright buildings i am
obviously obsessed
and so i'd love to know what was your
experience like let me know in the
comments below if you want to see more
make sure you subscribe and hit the bell
so you get notifications next time i
post a new video
and lastly please remember to give me a
thumbs up if you enjoy this video and
yeah i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you